en la primera noche después del
terremoto que ayer por la madrugada
sacudió el sudeste de Turquía miles casi
decenas de miles de personas pasarán la
noche al raso según las últimas
informaciones de última hora se calcula
que hay en torno de unos 1500 de
fallecidos tan solo en Turquía y luego
mil más también en el sur de la frontera
turca en Siria ahora mismo nos
encontramos en la ciudad de Adán a una
de las afectadas Aunque en Turquía es de
las menos afectadas sin embargo Eso no
significa que no haya habido fallecidos
aquí hay se cuenta algo más de una
decena y sobre todo en este antiguo
edificio de 14 plantas que han sido
completamente derruido sus antiguas
habitantes ahora tendrán que dormir a la
calle como además sus otros vecinos que
aquí mismo no pueden volver a sus casas
porque ha sido recomendado que no de
nadie entre de vuelta a sus casas una
vez
pasen no solo esta noche sino varias
noches en unas temperaturas que serán
gélidas en esta región En invierno se
llegan a temperaturas de varios grados
y las tareas de rescate de nuestras
espaldas aún continúan hace un rato
estaban los servicios citando los
servicios médicos para que viniesen a
atender una posible víctima que aún
podría ser con vida bajo los escombrosa
y como este edificio decenas de miles de
edificios de ruidoso